je me permets de soumettre à votre
discussion
la couverture du figaro magazine du ce
week-end on le fout pas systématiquement
loin de là mais le thème nous a semblé
intéressant il a d'ailleurs été traités
par d'autres confrères c'est celui d'une
forme d'entrisme peut-être en tout cas
c'est le constat que nous avons fait au
sein des universités l'entrisme
d'associations d'extrême gauche mais par
l'extrême gauche à l'ancienne des gens
qui sont adeptes de test comme le des
colonialismes la théorie du genre ou
l'islamo gauchisme j'ai envie de vous
poser la question très concrètement vu
de votre fenêtre
est ce que ça vous paraît un vrai un
vrai danger béatrice giblin vous êtes
vous êtes professeur émérite des
universités m'arrive encore d'y
enseigner j'ai enseigné à paris 8 qui
est une des universités mis en exergue
dans cet article
en novembre décembre donc ce n'est pas
bien loin bon et je ne nie pas que ça
existe et que ça existe déjà depuis
quelque temps mais c'est un phénomène
qui est extrêmement marginale quels sont
les départements touchés
on trouve ce genre paris 8 paris 10 aix
vincennes qui est très saine ni bas rhin
maintenant voilà mais c'est pas tout les
sens social moi j'ai enseigné dans les
sciences sociales c'est loin d'être tout
les sens social vous allez trouver
l'histoire mais une seule partie de
l'histoire et c'est pas tous les
ensembles d'un département histoire qui
est touché par cela vous allez trouver
la sociologie et c'est pas l'ensemble
d'un département de sociologie qui est
touché par cela et puis vous allez
trouver parfois l'anthropologie le ski
mort et une partie de la science
politique possible mais c'est loin
d'être tout c'est à dire cette façon de
présenter comme si les départements
d'histoire les département de sociologie
d'une certaine façon les sciences
sociales en général était totalement
noyauté puisque c'est le terme que vous
prenez pas par cela c'est une façon que
je trouve un peu pour le moins
tendancieux si vous voulez de présenter
les universités de sciences sociales qui
sont des lieux de débats qui sont des
lieux critique
assurément et je peux vous dire que les
débats sont extrêmement vives quand vous
avez assez
nombre de d'individus de militants on
cite par exemple le syndicat étudiant
les syndicats étudiants représentent
ainsi derrien à chaque élection j'ai
fait partie du bureau du conseil
d'administration et j'ai été élu au
conseil d'administration pendant des
années faire voter des étudiants à des
élections étudiantes mais c'est un
combat parce qu'ici il faudra encore qui
viennent cher monsieur moi j'ai siégé au
conseil d'administration pendant des
années ils ne sont pas si sombre et ils
ont fait venir dix couples esprits ne
sont pas nous dit vous nous dites
constat n'est pas faux mais ne
généralisons pas non seulement ne
généralisons pas mais prenons en compte
les réactions contre ça
c'est comme si vous faisiez de
l'ensemble des vingt-sept mille
étudiants de paris 8
des gens qui adhéraient totalement à ça
mais c'est un absolument faire si
beaucoup en tout cas y en a une qui
réagit pas beaucoup je le dis quand même
c'est la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur frédéric vidal acquis que nous
avons interrogés assez longuement c'est
judith waintraub qui résistent aussi qui
est allé la voir en guady mais vous
savez c'est marginal et toute façon
c'est la liberté académique donc
donc on fait ce qu'on veut barbara
lefebvre j'estime que j'entends tout à
fait votre témoignage de l'intérieur et
moi je connais aussi beaucoup
d'enseignants le maître de conférences
notamment qui doivent subir des
pétitions alors en effet vous avez
raison il participait pas beaucoup aux
élections syndicales
alors qu'est-ce qui pétitionnent contre
leurs enseignants contre les invités de
leurs enseignants dans certains
colloques donc croyez bien qu'il ya
aussi un public captif d'étudiants qui
est un peu un espèce de ventre mou
lequel une certaine forme d'inculture
historique et politique qui fait que en
ce moment c'est cette islamo gauchiste
mais c'est des coloniaux qui ramasse la
mise
parce qu'ils sont extrêmement actifs
donc moi je crois au contraire que ce
n'est pas une menace qu'il faut minoré
parce que c'est toujours la même chose
des minorités tyrannique sont toujours
les plus dangereuses donc effectivement
il ya une majorité d'une majorité
silencieuse qui subit en septembre 2018
à paris 7 il y avait eu une un projet de
colloque qui s'intitule et racé
discrimination raciale de l'école à
l'université et ça vous en avez pléthore
ce genre de colloque qui sont organisés
où vous retrouvez toujours les mêmes
enseignants eric fassin françoise vergès
tout nacira guénif voilà qui sont
toujours le même petit corpus
d'enseignants qui ont quand même des
postes assez prestigieux à l'université
enfin pas pour madame vergèze mais on
voit bien que ces obsédés de la
rassembler
et et qui est très intéressant c'est que
il se prétendait d'aidé coloniaux mais
en réalité ils ont le discours le plus
colonial qui existe parce qu'en fait ce
sont les rois de l'ethnicisation et pour
moi qui ai travaillé sur l'ethnicisation
dans l'afrique juste le lien entre
l'afrique précoloniale et l'afrique
coloniale
j'ai travaillé sur les processus
d'ethnicisation par l'administration
coloniale et je retrouve exactement les
mécanismes que sont ceux des des
colonies aujourd'hui qui assigne chacun
a une identité raciale voire à une
identité complètement inventé et
fantasmée et ces gens là sont
extrêmement dangereux parce que ce sont
les vraies boutiques et identitaire
aujourd'hui qui menace l'unité de la
république ça c'est absolument certain
donc je souligne la grande qualité du
travail de judith waintraub ici qui a
fait une véritable enquête
adrien la toux notamment dans cet
article on parle assez largement de
sciences po qui est un établissement que
vous connaissez bien puisque vous en
sortez vous êtes très jeune donc c'était
ya pas très longtemps vous l'avez centre
où la sambre vous le sentiez déjà ce set
7 vous l'a senti cette pression
alors moi je n'ai pas senti de pression
pour être honnête c'était pas violent
d'après moi j'ai une petite anecdote à
raconter c'est que quand j'étais à
sciences po il y avait ce qu'on appelle
le hidjab day donc en fait c'est des
étudiants de chaque année qu'ils
organisaient voilà la promotion du
foulard islamique à sciences po c'est
quand même assez particulier de voile à
devoir d en plus on se prétendant
féministe de voir quand même des
distributions de foulard islamique du
symbole patriarcale et sexiste pour à
peu près tout le monde je pense
donc voila c'était assez particulier
après je complète juste votre anecdote
on m'a dit que après cet ce dj et qui a
fait beaucoup de bruit le les
cotisations d'anciens élèves l'année
suivante c'est assez substantiellement
nation et pour être ancien élève et pour
avoir été concernées par ce sujet je
peux confirmer mais je vous laisse
continuer et bah sinon je les ai vus
dans mon travail puisqu'on a il ya
quelques mois si on arrivait à quelques
semaines à marion m'a fait une enquête
avec une collègue étienne girard alors
je pense que c'est intéressant je
rebondis sur ce que vous disiez c'est
vrai qu'on a peut-être tendance à
exagérer l'importance de ce mouvement
mais ce qui est préoccupant c'est que
justement vous parlez de débats et de
discussions c'est des gens qui refusent
le débat c'est des gens qui cherchent à
annuler des colloques qui cherchent à
boycotter des cours à empêcher des
sujets d'étude et je vous donne juste un
exemple on avait un témoignage dans l'
enquête de monde de mon confrère étienne
girard on avait un docteur en sciences
politiques qui nous avait dit c'est une
épave bourdieusien etc et que tu n'as
pas d'appétence pour les thèmes du
joueur est de la race tu n'as vraiment
pas beaucoup de chances d'obtenir un
poste dans certains départements de
sciences politiques donc c'est quand
même assez inquiétant de voir que
certains départements je suis d'accord
pas tous sont tenus par des gens qui en
fait un pose comme condition le fait
d'adhérer à leur thèse pour qu'on puisse
travailler quand je ne conteste
complètement ça est-ce qu'il faut pas
savoir comment se passe une commission
de recrutement d'un témoin
c'est un témoignage mais vous savez
comme moi que les témoignages sont à
prendre parfois avec des pincettes de
distance mais pour le coup vous allez
toujours en trouver il ya toujours des
gens qui ont été candidats qu'on peut
être recrutés la centaine de compost
pour le coup c'est quelqu'un en poste
mais vous allez y a pas de sélection par
des tableaux j c'est extrêmement sinon
c'est quand même très difficile parce
que hein
il y faut de maintenant la parité hommes
femmes il y faut il va j'aurais nom des
formes d'en face et quand même pas
toujours évident de trouver exactement
les gens qu'il faut pour penser comme
vous il faut que vous ayez des gens qui
viennent d'université extérieur pour
plus de la moitié
c'est là aussi vous savez moi j'ai fait
partie des commissions pour monter des
jurys quand on recrute c'est un casse
tête c'est extrêmement difficile à faire
parce qu'on a un certain nombre de
contraintes qui sont importantes il faut
pas qu'ils soient associés à votre
laboratoire parce qu'à ce moment là ils
sont récusés donc vous voyez vous avez
quand même un certain nombre de
garde-fous et vous avez un minimum de
nombre de gens qui sont correspondant
avec la taille de votre département et
de votre laboratoire
c'est à dire qu'on a parfois des
commissions qui sont avec 20 personnes
alors vous savez pour les trouver ça
vous en fait disent c'est à dire 11 pour
pouvoir avoir la majorité et qui pensent
tous comme ça je dis pas que ça puisse
pas arriver mais je dis que ça
vraiment c'est pas si grave sécheresse
ans on veut bien le dire
enfin c'est votre point de vue attention
parce que peut-être que c'est encore
marginal mais quand je regarde ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui aux états unis dans
les campus américains
on était donc dans la seconde moitié du
20e siècle c'était encore marginal vous
aviez tout les toutes les écoles post
post moderne qui est encore marge d'un
mille qui ont ensuite contaminé lors des
départements américains qui ensuite
imposer un climat intellectuel avec un
sectarisme qui aujourd'hui est quand
même assez ahurissant dans un pays qui a
longtemps chéri la liberté d'expression
et quand on voit ça et qu'on voit que
tout ceci finalement ce réexporte en
aura parce que là bas c'est quand même
des comptes actuels français c'est les
français qui ont exporté c'est cette
idéologie là aux états unis et ensuite
ses revenus dont on comprend on a une
expertise quelquefois as tu dises
essentiellement les indiens puisque les
phocéens
oui elle en saillie denis leur île il
est temps de parler d'eux mais je pense
que la france comme vous le savez n'a
pas l'histoire des états unis que la
situation de la discrimination raciale
depuis elle n'a pas la même histoire et
n'est pas encore là même que nous
n'avons pas eu d'esclaves sur notre
territoire
d'après toi tu connais bien se former
sur certains le poids du colonialisme
sur qui sur le maghreb sur
essentiellement l'algérie dans une
moindre mesure la tunisie et or je ne
vois rien oui et l'afrique subsaharienne
mais vous l'avez absolument pas se
priver si vous écoutez ce procès vous
écoutez bien le discours des sauteurs du
mot ils sont justement dans cette ré
interpréter je fais tous les concepts je
suis noir américain et je suis d'accord
avec vous et c'est la nation la pièce là
donc ça irait là je suis je voudrais
juste préciser une chose et c'est que
ces mouvements des coloniaux vivent sur
la bête parce que la plupart sont des
associations largement subventionnée
tout comme d'ailleurs beaucoup de ces
enseignants qui les qui les coptes et
qui les aident tous ces gens là qui
passent leur temps à dénoncer le racisme
d'état vivent en tout cas des subsides
de l'état donc là mais la contradiction
c'est aussi leur fort merci beaucoup à
tous les quatre il ya débat aussi un
chéneau internautes même s'il ya une
majorité assez forte presque les deux
tiers considèrent que oui c'est vrai ces
idées sont en train de
de de pénétrer l'université pour vous
faire votre propre point de vue je vous
renvoie au dossier du figaro magazine de
ce week end